ブーブー使っていたんですけどもブーバーんですけども綺麗に固まったんでもう rr
ファティできるんじゃないかなと私思いますけど今回付着するのがパです私は思って
しまいました
梅マって強いんですよあんなをという機械を動かす動力源って本当に強いだと思います
でも逆にあの動力げったいあろうあればだったらどこまで戦えるのかなと思いまして
今回安宅とかで作って僕がお手して言ってくださるんですけどもその車が大絵図分に
アロマレザーをつけて
車のタイヤと地面の雪部分にアロンアルファーをつけて接着させて検証県ドッキリ
みたいな感じでターゲットに乗ってもらって肌でそれが降っ運転っていうか発信できる
とかどうかを検証してみたいと思いますといいだから特急日ですここ
タイヤは多分寝3度寝床と対策接着するねそこをしっかりと止めればまずできると思い
ますさせる主
瓶のタイヤとかはもったいなくてやらないんですけどもオデッセイのタイヤが結構
すり減ってるか嘘の買い時なんで高の仕事としてちょっと実験に使うかなと思っており
ます
床もさせずにあどうあればべっダーツ組んであの取捨上でやるとちょっと問題になりだ
と思ったんでさぁ機に大家さんに強化を撮っておきましたというけど万全な態勢でいう
カット対応くっつける良いかと思います
ええええええ
[音楽]
ブーブーできる問題と思いますゼロ以下あり入ってあげる早速仕掛けていきましょう
タイヤは4つあるっで後ろサティですここに綺麗につけなきゃいけないんですけども
にょ動かす前に殺せチェーンだけにマークつけていきます
こんなんだろうなん
はい次だあどあなたを築きやすくするためにタイヤが45度回転するだけ
車を前進させます cure
[音楽]
[拍手]
これでもすぐアドの中をつけられる状態にしました
この先ペラってあのまぞん
でまず度をバックさせると完璧に泊まるというわけで瞬間接着剤なんで行っして
ファイルが置いてあった運慶
ずっとします多分一番最速で2体アクセスれるかというと思うぜ
を上げていきましょう
[音楽]
23はいいいえ
いません
せーの
4月号
このバンクに
はいいいえ
入っていません ok
もうちょいも強い
1本でほっとけボケ多分ラジ
入ってくるあれって挑むれたんですけどもまだチッっとか逆1なんでもうちょっと通学
塗っておきましょう
基本的な濡れてると思うんですけども好き no もうちょっと埋めていきます
を刺さっちゃう
ん
dee
ban
def
はいというわけですべての準備だと思いました大量のアロアの端を打ったんで多分も
止まっています
一発勝負だねこのままいくんですけどだしてあのーあ中でくるばの初動は止めるのが
取れないのか
毒通称早速ターゲットを読むと思いますでは
すごい大中チョッキてきてきてコスっ
ジャズうっ
オデッセイだけ様へと覧くださいません
オデッセイを実践前にマイルームにバーガーとか
ガタッ
そんな染め育っていううんその2
ゆっくりで最初は
push はいはいはいはいはいはいはい
そんな離村出ないんだけどね
ん
ゆっくり出てくるだけだねーっ
前
[音楽]
太陽アロンアルファでベッタベタにくっつけておいたんですよまあそういうことを直に
動いてアバ全然ダメだった